BUKI: I'm Buki.
I'm a software engineer
and a fine artist,
and this is how I code.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So when I'm coding from home,
I like to be super comfy
and really relaxed.
I'm sitting on my bed.
I have my fur because,
yeah, I'm extra.
So I have fur on my bed, I
have fairy lights as well,
and then I need loads of feed,
so I have my chocolate cookies
on the side and my tea.
And then I have
my sibling coming
in asking to use my Oyster
because I'm working from home.
When I'm on the
terminal, if I needed
to get to a specific file,
sometimes the file pathway
could be really long, so for me
to shorten it down to a word,
I would create an alias.
And the way that is done is that
you are still in the terminal,
and then you click
open.bash_profile.
When you do that,
you have to make sure
you're actually on the
home directory as well,
and that will open up
the bash_profile window.
And then within the window,
you write down the alias,
so the syntax with that
would be literally the word
"alias" followed by the
shortcut name, which
is whatever you want it
to be, and then = quotes.
And within the quotes, you write
the command or the file path
that you want to replace.
So it's the alias,
shortcut name, command.
Whoo!
[GIGGLES]